hey guys I'm Ryan right I am Jerry today
we're gonna check out from the channel
called all-time movies they have their
list of top 5 most violent movie scenes
I am interested in seeing what they
emphasize their troubles leave your
lovely I love this fight is imprisoned
in Tennessee what am i agency is one of
my favorite movies of all time top 5 for
sure
hi I'm Chris these are the top 5
disgustingly violent movie scenes now
these scenes go beyond gore and painful
sound effects no remorse of territory
warning this video contains disturbing
so I don't wanna watch this actually you
remote this it beyond brain detail
number 5
Scarface that's right at number 5 is
Scarface is close encounter with a
chainsaw
when Cuban drug lords want money they
don't do it by halves they do it by many
many icky chunky pieces of human flesh
it's a terrifyingly horrific scene and
of course it ends in a bloody shootout I
mean why wouldn't it honorary mention
goes to casinos head squeezed and nasty
game of baseball mad gangsters are dicks
if you have a 40 now the raid - yeah
yeah action movies have their fair share
of gruesome kills sure but the prison
riot scene from the roof I just wanna
see you next the cake so let's see we're
in the right we've got my herbs tossing
stabbing leg breaking jaw open Skull
Crushing and shooting and I guess more
stabbing and it's all in the mud it is
kind of beautiful number 3 irreversible
what's this alright alright stop me if
you have heard this one before two guys
right they walk into a gay club they
stop bragging with another guy now that
guy beats up and tries to rape one of
the friends while the member on them
hilariously masturbate
then the other friend comes to the
rescue and endlessly beats the rapist
head to a pulp with a fire extinguisher
hilarious right yeah hello first that is
how irreversible begins and as a story
unravels we find out this horrific
murder was sparked on by the brutal anal
rape of a woman
ordinal it's pretty hard to stomach
number twos like Tolan Antichrist sex
and violence do not mix nicely just like
Willem Dafoe finds out in this scene
where his insane wife played by
Charlotte Gainsbourg knocks him out
and jerks him off until he ejaculates
blood then she draws a hole in his leg
and attaches a grindstone through it so
he caught her in a way so he tries and
gets chased with a shovel
you might think that that's the worst of
it but you'd be wrong the film climaxes
with Charlotte masturbating and cutting
off her clitoris with a pair of rusty
scissors mmm lovely number 1 a Serbian
phone this whole movie is disgusting do
not watch it don't even attempt to watch
it if you are anywhere near squeamish
it's a twisted tale about a
down-on-his-luck porn star it gets
dragged into a part of this now
along with other violence against women
you know the usual
it ends with a bloodbath involving rape
child abuse debt by literal skulking
suicide and that all-time favorite
necrophilia this film is by a first-time
director writer producer and the whole
thing reeks of an attempt to grab
people's attention as well as making you
sick it simply sucks oh whoa whoa whoa
not like that not like this
and I'd like this so if you're still
watching and not vomiting into your
toilet by now what did you think of this
list
what violent movie scenes make you feel
queasy and uneasy audition maybe let me
know in the comments below thanks for
watching wartime movies if you've made
it this far why not check out Micah's
list of the worst movie sex scenes ever
it is so bad that abort isn't good see
you next time if it would give you great
pleasure if I were to suck your [ __ ] for
12 hours if I maybe presumptious haha is
possibly the worst seduction line in the
history of film it's turkey time
Oh God huh yeah no no no I'm thinking
about lunch me my god Ellison okay dude
I did not know that happens an
antichrist oh yeah
yeah I think there's a lot of genital
mutilation of it my god I've had a girl
join me often enough times to where I
started you know squirting out blood no
that's 100 free clitoris I can't believe
they put that in a [ __ ] movie what's
up with Lars von German hey Lars von
Trier I mean he's working something out
he's working some Islands green yeah he
just stopped he's an easy seeing actor
should stop agreeing to do these movie
terrify this accent oh yeah that prison
fight from Ray - yeah that was brutal
like Veronica has never seen the ray
door ray - and the Ray too is on HBO and
I was like you gotta watch this just at
least one fight scene yeah I picked the
wrong fight scene wrong I mean the road
is like I don't remember the scene being
so [ __ ] rude
oh yeah it's brutal oh yeah cuz I hate
all that [ __ ] what was that called Malik
boys like ripping his job
ya hate that you go away the first time
remembering like wow the way they made
that scene kind of all like one it looks
like one shot it's all I say Cannes
you're like really right in it and it's
like all happening in one long take
that's what you leave with him in the
second time you're like oh but this is
so much more disgusting yeah yeah cuz I
ever have that stuff I was just like oh
you know everything he was shot cool
my name is but watching again I was like
oh my god this is so disturbing like I'm
a little surprised they chose that
particular fight for memory because it
feel like a couple of the other ones
were more like gruesome but no no it was
sheer volume at all yeah first of all
dude oh do you that sounds [ __ ]
insane your verses were heard of it it's
like told it's like a rape revenge movie
this totally reversed so it starts with
the guy finding and killing the dude or
whatever and then it works its way back
to the beginning of that night or
whatever so it's memento but with a rape
revenge story I guess yeah I'm not 100%
sure how they cut it either were kind of
I think I I think what it is we saw they
just portray gay people horribly in
there no yeah I saw it seen from
irreversible and had class once somebody
brought it in and it was like the really
nasty scene that he only mentioned by
name oh man well that first scene
apparently he's about to get raped by
one of the gay guys and everyone just
starts jerking off looked at I was it's
a heavy man
dude if that happened to me a real wife
in might turn me off nope nope not it it
wouldn't go go watch your reversible
have a great I mean and work him into it
you know like I like I like the I like
to plot playing pretend you know I would
be very interested to hear yeah if buddy
ever managed a successful irreversible
role play scenario and upon hearing such
information I would stay the hell away
from me oh the Serbians Oh ever I feel
easy have a copy i I didn't deal with
you have a copy yeah my boss just came
through one day she was like hey we got
a copy subhumans gonna be doing serbian
film anybody want dude serbian film i
hear that has like baby rape in there I
haven't seen yet but there's a yeah
there's a lot is just like unbelievably
grotesque mm-hmm it's a it's a message
movie I saw absurd net I think that was
it's number one most violent movie -
it's weird I like that her a Cannibal
Holocaust I have a friend who is a bit
of like a an extreme horror junkie I
remember her saying that Serbian film
was not a tough
really yeah she said like you know it's
kind of hard to get through but but not
the worst did you [ __ ] her
no no she she dates a good friend of
mine and you know we were we were
colleagues we were working together that
was mostly how I knew her this story
could have ended a lot more interesting
if you had [ __ ] her if I were to get
killed we go back I would like to get um
skull-fucked do you mean that's how you
would want to die or you would want to
have it after the fact just to make it
worse how long after um whatever no you
know my time I died I was gonna be
ambulance coming gotta get I am like
maybe we're in the coroner's office you
know and one of the orderlies scar-faced
one doesn't really bother me a lot of
people consider that like such a
disturbing scene I saw a movie when I
was young and it's actually never really
bothered me that scene they're just
threatening him with it right are they
threatening him with it and he kills
someone in front of Scarface a friend of
his oh but you don't see it like you
just see the guy's reaction in his face
and I think it's just the the the
disturbing nature of the scene it's up
because if somebody man do d'avin it's
different from like a gun or a knife
even I mean both of those things are
terrifying but like if somebody had you
held up in a bathroom a [ __ ] chainsaw
is like it's so over the top that that
would be em and probably asked a carnage
at the time it was released to probably
has something to do with yeah they
didn't love chainsaws as much as we do
now yeah we have a [ __ ] franchise
called salt anyway guys thanks for
tuning into the channel if you're new to
it you can subscribe to the real rejects
you check out reasons to Gerry on this
chain you can you could follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope and we're going to VidCon this
week so if you're going to VidCon you
should say hi who knows maybe they'll
let you skull fun I would love to see
that I can put my eye back right um I
know I'm wondering what the best you
know I'm Lord you just have to make a
hole somewhere God would love to get
gaming know you know you probably
wouldn't love that I wouldn't know what
was I woman gaming me
I never gangbang strap-ons exists well
they don't have to have a strap-on so it
could just be a reverse game so gang
banging you it seems like they're
dominant in the situation at which point
you don't really have much of a say over
there
oh but strap-ons unless you have some
kind of woman's right unless these are
all yours John Raptors